Speaker 1: Let's go next to Audrey from
Georgia. Audrey, you're on the air.
Speaker 4: Hi, David Iglesias. We've talked
before XOM, but I had an interesting question
four years on yesterday, one to ask. So I
was I studied Chinese in college and I was
talking with my Chinese professor yesterday.
Speaker 1: Now, sorry, I'm sorry to interrupt.
Did you study Mandarin or Cantonese Mandarin?
Speaker 4: Oh, OK, good. And I came to the
conclusion that I think China is a little bit
like kind of I think we treat them very biased in
our media and especially in our education. And I
wanted to get your take on that. Do you think that
China in many ways is sort of like demonized in
our media? Like if you look in the news, it's
always something bad about them. There's never
any report. Some like the good things going on
in there, like scientific research and everything.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I would generally speaking agree
that there is a I mean, listen, China
is an economic adversary. There is no
question about that, but they're also an economic
partner, and that's what makes this so complex.
On the one hand, we have an economy that for
decades has been based on being able to get cheap
stuff from China. That's what it is. If we didn't
get cheap stuff from China and we couldn't quickly
get it elsewhere and had to bring all production
domestically, we'd be buying American, as some
people say, but things would cost dramatically
more. And what I see is in a cemetery in
if we want to recognize China as an economic
adversary and along with Russia up there with
the U.S. as being in a battle to be the
major of the three major superpowers,
that's fine. That's accurate. I have no
problem identifying China in that way.
But so many of the people who wildly talk about
China virus and intellectual property theft in
this stuff seem to not know or recognize that
our entire way of life, including the purchasing
power that we have, is based on the fact that
we manage. We get so much of our day of our of
our products from China, and I think it would be
great to have a more balanced perspective on that.
Speaker 4: All right, and I was more talking about
also, like in education, very few people in the
United States seem to know anything about like the
politics or the general like daily life of what
it's like for people in China. They just that's
Speaker 1: not super surprising, though, that
it's very common that people people in the United
States also know very little about the lives of
people in Russia or in Japan or in Denmark. Now
you could say, well, China is more important to
know about for the reasons you're laying out. But
it's not surprising that U.S. education, at least
in the K through 12 level, is very useful.
Speaker 4: I mean, like in U.S. education,
we learn all about how the Japanese and British
parliament and everything works. But there's
absolutely no involvement in no other countries,
such as like how Russia's or how China's
politics work. And I think it's something
important that we need to recognize if we're
going to have those important political
discussions all over the news about,
you know, like China getting rid of term limits
or anything. If you're going to understand that,
you have to have at least a basic knowledge of
Speaker 1: how it works. I agree with you. I
agree with you completely, Audrey. Thank you
for the call. You're welcome. All right. There
is Audrey. Let's go next to Oh, we don't often get
calls from Idaho. Let's go to Barbara from Idaho.
Speaker 5: Hey, David, can you hear me, Barbara?
Speaker 1: I can hear you fine.
Or at least they could. Are you still there?
Barbara's gone, that's too bad. Barbara, left,
was really looking forward to that. I would
love to know what, like what's happening
in Idaho? It's a very it's a closed book for
me. Let me put it that way. Let's go to Tyler
from St. Louis. Tyler, you're on the air.
Speaker 4: Hey, David. I'm not eating a
sandwich this time.
Speaker 1: OK, good.
Speaker 2: I guess I didn't really have a
question, I just wanted to apologize to the Pacman
community for subjecting their ears to that.
Speaker 1: You listened back and the the
sandwich eating was a distraction during your
last call, in other words. Oh, certainly,
yeah. Yeah, yeah, well, listen, I think I think
apology accepted. Now we've we've sorted it out.
All right. That's all I have to
say. OK, good, but next time,
definitely mute the discord billings. That
would be the thing to work on for the next call.
Speaker 3: Yeah, there's another one, yep.
Yeah, that's something to do to push, to talk,
I don't know how to turn that off.
Speaker 2: I have no idea why
my microphone picks that up.
Speaker 1: Yeah. All right. Very good.
Thank you for the call. We've gotten everything
up to date as far as that's concerned. Let's
go next to Nate from Rhode Island. Nate, you were
on the air. Nate, from Rhode Island, you're on the
air. And Nate from Rhode Island
gone, wow, things taking a turn.